uh from mit and peking university talk
about quantum algorithms for escaping
satellites
thank you thank you for the nice
introduction
hi everyone today i'm going to talk
about quantum algorithms for escaping
from saddle points
and this is a joint work with chen nija
and jacqueline and actually
i'm currently still doing my postdoc mit
by the way
formerly drunken university in this
first semester
okay so let's get started so today i'm
going to talk about
optimization so for optimization in
general we are going to have a
n-dimensional function that maps r to
the n to r
and the goal is to minimize this
function and such kind of optimization
problem is a core topic in math
the radical computer science operations
research etc
so previously there has been a lot of
study for such kind of meditation
problem
and i think in general people are quite
interested about their approval
guarantee
so a main class that have been done
extensively started is the convexation
problem
so it is well known that common
recommendation can be solved in
polynomial time and there are a lot of
well-known methods such as the eukaryote
method or interior point method etc
so like um uh in in classical theory
people have been really pushing forward
to get the best understanding of
product communication algorithms and the
best-known result is actually on due to
this
foreign so if you want to have a bond in
terms of like polynomial in terms of the
dimension and but only like polylog in
terms of accuracy
uh basically we want to have a level or
epsilon here
the state of that result due to thesis
program hella has complexity like um
quadratic in terms of query on cubic in
terms of time
so actually um there has been a
following follow-up work along this line
so basically quantum it is known that
assume you have such kind of quantity
evaluation oracle
so basically we can evaluate the
corresponding function in supervision
and also uh for customization there is
typically a contact set
such that we require this x to be so if
we have this kind of
we can query for whether a point is set
inside this on convex set or not which
is called the membership article
if we can also do this in civilization
we know that uh there is previous work
due to
epidemic at all and also chat privacy at
all that can basically solve the problem
in only like linear quantum queries and
similar in cubic time
so this is a very nice story a very also
very brief story about collectionization
and you may ask whether this is the end
of the story
so actually there are much more things
in optimization other than convexation
and in particular for instance maybe
from the perspective of machine learning
there are at least two main concerns for
this so on the one hand for instance
a lot of lots a lot of loss functions
machine learning models so basically we
know that we want to train machine
learning model
and it's just equivalent to optimizing
your synthesis function
such kind of function machine learning
are typically non-complex
so in particular for instance this is
just very good looking this is a convex
function and we know that as collect
function
it actually has a unique local minimum
which is just a global one
but this is just too ideal and what
actually um people encounter in real
situations
is something like this and this is not
so good because it has so many local
minima
so just like if you just trivially use
the connectionization algorithm this is
not going to work and there are also
some other concerns that
in particular in practice i think
especially for for these days for
instance like
optimization in machine learning is that
in many common cases we typically have
huge dimensions
and but sometimes i think we are okay
with relatively large absolute i mean
a lot of like data center robots and
some and also for a lot of situations
we are not that careful about the
precision factor so in particular for
instance as i just mentioned that a lot
of co-optimization balance they
basically have
a poly in terms of m but polylog in
terms of our absolute
so if we got to choose i think in a lot
of real applications
we actually want the log to be in front
of ends
instead of in front of unbound over
absolute so this is actually something
we really want to pursue for
and actually such kind of algorithm
called almost dimensional free method
okay so let's now talk about
non-convertibilization because this is
what after all we have to encounter now
so the most common method for
uh optimization in general and also
works for non-customization is the
gradient descent method
so basically it is a iterative method at
iteration t
here assume that you are at a point x t
you are going to move forward
that assume you have a gradient you know
the gradient at this point
you are going to have a step size and
you are going to move forward like this
so this gradient descent method is
actually working
very well if on the other hand for
instance if you know the function is
l smooth uh basically satisfies this
kind of licious property in terms of the
gradient
you can show that using like uh like
l or epsilon square iterations you can
basically reach a point whose gradient
is
at most absolute so this is very
first order derivative of the function
this is typically called like the
absolute approximate
first order stationary point the
question is is that's good enough
so let's just take an example of this
landscape so the landscape that i just
showed in the previous page
so the one main issue that for
non-college
non-convex organization especially in
high dimensional situation is the center
point problem
so for instance in this landscape we
have this this and this platform is also
like a center point
so let's in particular like take a look
at this standard point
so assume that if you are maybe at this
point if you do do great and decent
you will move forward actually or you
will go down at the beginning but
unfortunately you will be trapped at a
certain point and similar at this side
if you do breathing decent you'll be
trapped like here
and also like here so this is something
not really good and for instance we
really want to have
something instead that we want to reach
some local minimum like things
this is really what we want
so and also on the other hand i think in
general i think these are some
general points but actually most of them
are actually true in
most situations is that for a lot of
problems local minima are actually
not that bad they're actually nearly as
good as a global minima
and they are just supported by some
landscape results but it is known that
saddle points like the set of points
that just showed in the previous page
are typically quite bad and actually you
can give highly sub-optimal solutions
but unfortunately set up points are
ubiquitous and find the global minimum
is in general empty heart
so from a theoretical perspective i
guess if you want to solve a
non-compromisation problem
typically the first step is that we want
to escape from some other points and
for instance we are satisfied with like
an absolute approximate local mean
actually this is actually a little bit
hand-wavy and like a more precise
definition should be like
excellent approximate second order
stationary point so why second order
so here we really want to make sure that
the curvature looks very well so we not
only want to have the
the assumption that the gradient is
small but also we want to make sure that
at the point you you give me this x
epsilon
it's hashing matrix it's close to a
positive semi-definite matrix
so basically the the smallest eigenvalue
of the hashing matrix
is you see is actually not a very large
negative number here and also here to to
make sure
the the to make this work we also need a
extra assumption that the function f
here is row hashing districts
so basically the second order here the
second order
the road here is also have this kind of
auto enjoy such kind of vicious property
so this square root of row times epsilon
is just
uh this is just standard it's just a
standard choice in existing literature
or in other on the other side you may
think of this as
because this is like a second order
property you think about taylor
approximation
so this just is the thing that commonly
appears intel approximation but the
second order you just square that
and this actually this is the most like
the the most
common choice of the parameters here to
be uh to be existing like the the
epsilon square of row concepts
but actually you can make some other
choices and this but this is like the
standard thing
that we are going to discuss about today
okay so let's now talk about existing
results in escaping setup once and
actually we are going to introduce our
results
so this is just the list of the previous
works and actually it is well known that
if you have a hashing oracle if you
can query for the hash matrix at the
uh the the the hashing matrix and the
at the points that you give to me and
actually this can be done
very efficiently this just like
something like the newton method and
they're just like improved version of
the newton method
actually it is showing the natural and
projects results in like 15 years ago
that basically the per complexity
can be something like well or epsilon to
the 1.5 so there are some
fallout works and actually the main
focus on this slide is to improve the
oracle
so why do we want to uh be cautious
about that
so although like this kind of hashing
oracle thing is like a folklore maybe
you can use the newton method to solve
the problem
but the issue is that this is the
hashing matrix is an n by n matrix and
this
is just two cos in practice that's just
written just
writing down the whole matrix how it's
going to have a cos of n squared
and if the n here is large this is just
too expensive
and as you can see it is a trend in the
classical literature here is that we
want to do simpler and simple oracle
well we want to keep like a polylog
bound in terms of the dimension factor
ends
and for instance there's an article
called the hashing vector product and
actually what is the most important
thing is that
in this results due to genetic how it
can be shown that
only using the gradient or i mean at the
point x you tell me the corresponding
gradient of
like the natural effects you only use an
ingredient oracle which is the first
order information you can actually ratio
you can actually escape from center
points and reach second order stationary
points and this is really similar
results due to diagram and proved
such kind of things so in this work we
uh
we follow this kind of chain actually we
use an even simpler article
so we use the quantum evaluation article
so we do the quantum article does not
even require the gradient
so we only have the zeros all the
information that we can calculate the
function in superposition
and actually we have such kind of bound
and actually in terms of the bound here
we actually matches the best known
classical result into t
in terms of our excellent dependence and
furthermore we can achieve a cubic
quantum speed up in terms of
m so their classical value is log n to
the sixth
and our quantum down here is only log
into the two
and the just mentioned the oracle is
also similar here
so this is the main result that i'm
going to introduce on today and i think
later in the next part of my talk i'm
going to introduce the technical details
for this
okay so the main idea for in general for
escaping from center points i mean
starting from the classic work due to gi
towel is this idea
called gradient descent and actually
this is not a very hard to understand
so as i just mentioned at the at the
previous slide so if you just do greedy
and decent
so unfortunately you will be trapped at
this saddle point like this
or maybe if you do this you'll also be
unfortunately trapped at the center
point
but actually you don't have to be that
rigid maybe you want to think about some
idea like this
that you want to shake the point when
the gradient is too small so for
instance if you do gradient
descent again again maybe you're at this
point
if you are at the point around this you
will notice that reading decent won't
move forward a lot actually because the
breathing is just too small
so if you're actually at such kind of
point you can just shake it and for
instance
you're lucky enough if you check to this
point that you're actually quite good
because if you later
do great and decent you will actually
you're getting down
to to this point to to later points
actually quite good because
you have already successfully speak from
the second point
so this is just like a very rough idea
and very intuitive
and i guess it is quite easy to
understand
but there are some cells that we want to
be careful about
so for instance we want to be careful
about the radius of the perturbation
so if this is too large for instance the
radius is
as large as this you want to be careful
because that with a very
uh actually uh it's not you're going to
have a non-negligible
probability that you're probably going
to is a radius
you're going to move backward like this
this which is not something you really
want to
see and actually on the other hand if
the the perturbation rate is too small
for instance if it's as small as this
then the perturbation will work but it
actually will only move the point a
little bit i mean from this point to
this point
then you probably still need a lot of
alterations of 3d and descent to
really move through this direction
actually stay from the center point
so this choice of the radius is actually
uh quite
tricky and also you want to be uh
careful about the way that you want to
make the perturbation for instance this
is just like the way i draw a ball here
but maybe
maybe you want to draw a square and
maybe you want to consider some other
maybe
gaussian distributions or something like
that so what is the most efficient
approach here
and also uh we have been you can talk
about gradient decent gradient descent
and actually there are some alternatives
of the gradient descent maybe some other
methods can
move forward faster so these are like
the the three main points about like
this
very intuitive idea of perturbing decent
and actually the the work of xenital
just follow this approach and make some
changes and actually make everything
rigorous so
in uh the work of tiato instead of the
vanilla version of the gradient descent
their work used a method called the next
sort of accelerated gradient descent
so this is something i'm probably not
going to introduce a lot today because
this is like a folklore
knowledge in optimization theory and if
you're interested maybe you can just
check wikipedia or corresponding
textbooks
so just using the natural accelerated
gradient descent actually
can do the job and also on the other
hand the perturbation radius in that
paper is
specifically chosen to be something like
epsilon over log n to the five
so in that paper it is going uh got to
be like absolute over some poly log n
so actually it's not going to be enough
and the quality
after making some calculations it is
showing that the degree of the
log n here got to be logged into the
file so
though in their work uh in the work of
tn cloud the final algorithm is that if
the
the norm of the gradient is smaller than
absolute and no perturbation has been
happening like log n steps your the the
the algorithm is just going to make a
perturbation uh uniformly in such kind
of fall
with research kind of radius and
actually
it can be shown that using this after
making the perturbation you do
accelerate the gradient descent
so it can be shown that it is going to
take uh
approximately long end steps to move to
make sure that the function is going to
decrease by like one overlocked into the
five
and actually the convergence rate only
speaking of in terms of epsilon
is like 1 or epsilon to the 1.75 so if
you put everything together the overall
computational cost is going to be logged
into the 6
or absolutely 1.75 so this is just like
a very quick sketch about what happened
in the classical state of our result due
to g and
oh so next a very natural question here
is that whether we can
give a quantum speed up following such
kind of approach so our intuition is
that we firm
we think about this from a very high
level perspective so we noticed that
in this algorithm uh the perturbation
really plays a crucial role
a crucial role here but we notice that i
think the main obstacle
here is just like the classical radius
is too bad i mean
making some calculations you see like
this actually you have like a logan to
the
factory here so very natural question
here is that can we give a quantum speed
up for this step
so maybe in general we want to maybe we
say this is like a hybrid quantum
classical algorithm
we will still want to do this kind of
gradient design but just for this very
single step for this
perturbation kind of thing can we
actually make uh the story um
we may maybe uh make a more clever
choice here
so in particular i think from a high
level perspective
so if you're near a center point so this
is really like uh
we if what we say from the center point
it's really like we want to say some
some poor landscapes that we do we don't
really want but actually
this is actually somehow really like the
quantum channeling effect
in terms of quantum mechanics so for
instance like this is like a figure
that i copied from the internet so
classically if you have like a potential
well here you probably
the gradient descent you actually
usually do gradient descent you're
actually just going to fall back and
it's
actually quite difficult for classical
algorithm to climb up such kind of heal
but quantumly if you have a potential
well like this you can make some
calculations into the schrodinger's
equation
you're going to have another digital
probability that you can turn it through
from the left-hand side to the
right-hand side
so i think um if uh if this like this
topic is too long to read
i mean a tldr for this for one sentence
that we just make the idea of rhythmic
using a quantum simulation of the
schrodingers equation
so this is like the genetics equation i
mean for this wave function here
and the main trick here is that we uh we
basically consider this function f
we just choose the function of this
potential
well here should be the function that we
are going to optimize that
we are going to optimize with and
actually when we are actually around the
center point we are just going to use
quantum simulation
to make sure that we can escape from
cell point much faster than the
classical
reading descent okay this is like
something still very high level and
maybe let me get into more details
so uh let's just first make this
assumption that near saddle point
because like
at the setup point you see the courage
is just going to be
roughly being characterized by the by
the hash matrix so maybe let's first say
that the function is well approximated
by a quadratic function
so after having this assumption so for
instance you have the function f
x to have such kind of form and we
assume that we start with a gaussian a
standard gaussian blur
packet so it's a standard gaussian would
pack it like this
so keep in mind that this is just like
the the coefficient
of the quantum states and you should
consider like the magnitude you
actually have a square here and this
just becomes the standard gaussian
distribution
so the main point is that assume you
have a quadratic
potential function f here you can you
can see the simulation of the gaussian
wave packet
the the the main effect we are going to
see is that
the is that after you evolve in the
schrodinger equation
the wave function is still going to be
gaussian and there is a very interesting
phenomenon in terms of the change of the
variance
so if the lambda here is larger than
zero this is just going to be something
we have as a harmonic oscillator and
you're actually going to see
that the variance is specifically as an
oscillator is specifically like a
like a cosine function up to some shifts
but i think another on the other hand
is very interesting that the lambda here
is actually smaller than zero
in that case you will encounter an
exponential rate of
discretion but basically this uh this
variance is going to grow up
exponentially fast
and when lambda equals to zero this is a
quadratic function here
so as a summary is that uh for this
specific denominator we are going to
have
exponential dispersion rate when lambda
is smaller than zero quadratic for
lambda equals to zero and
at most constant in this harmonic
oscillator effect the lambda is larger
than zero
so what does that mean so this is
basically the lambda that we showed in
this paper
and actually um maybe this is a little
bit abstract to
uh on to to read but let's talking talk
like this
so if we're near a set of points then by
the math definition
we know that at least one of the
eigenvalue is going to be smaller than
minus
or square root of a row times absolute
so
because the dispersion is just so large
and also a given assumption that the
function is is quadratic
even all the other directions go
backwards i mean for instance
there are like a positive eigen
direction so maybe it's just like a
harmonic oscillator effect
but this we know that it's both a
constant of
of all these kind of directions but with
high probability the function value
still decreases much
so for instance if this is like the the
center point and we know
because we know that this is a center
point that we want to escape from
and we know that while the eigenvalue is
at most
this minus square root of times rho the
square root of
rho times epsilon so this is going to be
the direction of the exponential
dispersion and this is going to mean
maybe like all the other noises or the
backwards
after all we are going to still move
from this point
oh sorry after all we are going to still
move from this point to that point and
you can actually see that for this point
doing gradient descent is still quite
good actually we can stay from the
saddle point
so this is only the perturbation step
about how does that combine with
gradient descent
so in our work we uh we basically have
roughly speaking have a quantum
algorithm like this
so as a as i mentioned this is really
like a hybrid quantum classical
algorithm
that we just do perturb gradient decent
with quantum simulation
so with similar similar comparative
similarly on to the classical algorithm
we also we don't protect a lot
we we have basically we have a trigger
the trigger is that the
the the the gradient is going to be that
too small so as long as the gradient so
when the
the gradient is too small and you have
not heard the point for
for some attributions i think basically
for the
key prime representations to be
something like a
log n so if you have not a particular
for a while
uh basically then you just do the
perturbation but what is totally
different compared to the classical
algorithm is that our perturbation is
truly quantum so it's not like we draw
like a ball with radius and this radius
are absolutely
overlooked into the 5. we just do the
quantum simulation as i just mentioned
in the previous slide
and actually the algorithm is just like
this so we just do quantum simulation
and after we do quantum stimulation we
just do gradient descent
and actually we do a few step of great
and decent and actually
uh if we the product is not not
unsuccessful and after we trick
this like the number of iterations here
is more than on square key
prime again we are probably going to do
it again but in general it's just like
we replace this step
by the so we replace the classical
perturbation by radius by this quantum
simulation
and the other parts are just similar
so i think there are still some other
things that we want to
pin down because this is we just
mentioned that we
used the idea of quantum simulation to
replace the classical elevation
a very natural question is that what is
the computational cost of this
field step so in particular i mean we
talk about like we want to have
alterations queries of the function f
what is the quantum part complexity of
simulating the schrodinger's equation
here
so this is like the first remaining
question and actually uh because the
schrodinger's equation this kind of wave
function is it's just
essentially a partial differential
equation so we follow closely to a
previous
quantum pde solver due to chaos at all
so in charge at all uh the
it's just like we want to consider some
numerical method we have to
the whole space into some uh grids with
satellite a and we are happy to see that
that the work of child set up can choose
the a to be something like poly in terms
of
n a log bar epsilon and basically in
this case this um
this laplacian operator is actually
going to be discretized to this
kind of laplacian matrix and actually
going to be the laplacian matrix of the
graph of the wrist
and actually uh you can this can be
encountered by this kind of identity
here
so basically after making some
calculations you can make sure that
original
schrodinger's equation in the continuous
space after making the discretization
is going to be such going to be reduced
to such kind of problem
and this kind of problem this this l is
just going to be
as i just mentioned the laplacian matrix
of the graph of the grid
and this matrix speed is actually going
to get that matrix
such that the entry for the green x axis
going to be half of
entry effects on the corresponding
diagonal entry
so this is probably going to be looking
much more familiar because this is a
standard hamiltonian simulation problem
and furthermore we want to be uh be
even more notice that this hamiltonian
simulation problem has a very special
structure
uh in the sense that this part the slot
passing part is
actually dominating because the sentence
a here is actually small so
so this part is going to have a much
larger norm compared to the b
part so this part of laplace is going to
be dominating but actually this is
independent of the potential well here
because this is just like the way how
you're going to discretize the space to
solve the partial differential equation
so this is actually independent of the
queries that we are going to make
the query is only going to be the end of
the matrix b
here which is going to encode the
function evaluation here
but this is actually diagonal and we all
know that in hamiltonian simulation
diagonal harmony is very easy to be
simulated
and actually for this kind of special
structure we have like one part and
another part
and there is a new enchantment quantum
simulation called
stimulation under the interaction
picture due to low end vf and actually
we just call this a result
from them and actually we make some
calculations we show that the
quantum curve complexity of simulating
this specific kind of
schrodinger's equation is roughly
speaking going to be like tilde o of rt
times log n
up to like a polylog factors and what
happened in the fraction here
so this is very good because um as we
mentioned that
uh the the the we really want to make
the simulation of the schroedinger's
equation here
so we we are very happy to see that
classically we have the
like maybe t number of iterations
quantumly we only incur like a local
overhead in terms of the simulation
here and the key factor here is they
must exist because in general for
quantum simulation you are going to have
a linear overhang this is not something
this is just in general
inevitable here
so this is the the question for the
quantum part complexity and there is
another
very natural question here is that i
think as i just discussed that we talked
about partial differential equation and
basically this potential well for the
quadratic case
but another very natural question is
that is the quadratic approximation a
too strong assumption
so this is definitely a very natural
question here and we are able to
to to mention that the answer is no the
in general for the general case can be
approximated by the pareto case with a
very small overhang
so for for proving this we actually
caught some existing tools from
a partial differential equation
functional analysis so in particular
there's a paper due to round purgan who
is actually a
phys medal winner that there is a very
solid result on growth of the sublevel
norms in linear schrodinger's equation
and actually by calling their work we
can show that the change of the
the grid in the l2 norm is almost like a
like flock t to some fixed like a
constant alpha here
and actually using this result you do
wrong again we can show that
uh if we have the original function f to
be the potential
function and also on the other hand we
have a
quadratic approximation near the saddle
point so this f
and the function f q here so we have
this two partial function the
weakness the corresponding simulation of
the schrodinger's equation
i want to basically we want to measure
the outcome and compare the
corresponding distribution so one is
like
the p c and the other is p c prime so we
notice that
the total various total a very
variational distance between these two
distributions they're actually
quite small and actually making some
calculations it is funded by this
this expression so as long as the time
simulation time g
is small enough this is basically
non-negligible and basically after
making
some calculations we can make sure that
even if
we have the quadratic approximation this
is only a small overhead
and everything as a destination can
still carry us over
basically the the complexity beyond
okay i think this basically covers the
technical details that i want to mention
and maybe let's just put everything
together
so the final quantum algorithm is going
to look like this so like
the name of the algorithm is a little
bit long here but it is like
accelerated gradient decent because this
is also what is achieved in uh
in the work of a classical work of china
at all that replace the accelerated
gradient descent by gradient descent
but furthermore we don't like to occur
with this kind of radius the uniform
distribution but we just replace it by
quantum simulation
so uh once uh you know well that for
instance we have been known that there
has been no perturbation
like a square t of prime steps we just
make the perturbation and after making
the perturbation we just do this kind of
accelerated gradient descents
so in this work we can actually uh
basically uh by uh working through all
these kind of ideas we can show that the
quantum correct complexity for sowing
the
escaping from center point problem is at
most like
like this factor so this part is exactly
the same compared to the classical
algorithm
but this iota square this is this iota
is just everything with small roughly
speaking
i mean also you have of course you have
a laptop and
in terms of dimension here so the
classical work uh in the girl instead of
a
state of the art work have a bound leg
out at the sixth power
and here we will have an iota to the two
so why is this the case
so i guess this is probably going to
make the situation
more clear so roughly speaking the
algorithm has done three steps as a
transmission so if the gradient
is large we apply cellular ingredient
descent if the gradient is small we run
from simulation with time like oh i'll
flop n
and measure the outcome and actually we
apply for the first
for simplicity we can actually apply a
brilliant descent for long
alterations and we then go to step one
or step two depending
on the norm of the gradient descent
so classically the balance is basically
i mean i mean this part is
is um i mean we can directly compare
them but they are a little bit different
just classically it's just making the
perturbation you you do like login steps
of
gradient descent but quantum layer here
we just make plot insteps of
sorry the simulation time to be logged
which is like a continuous factor here
but roughly speaking this overhead is
the same so quantum is much better in
terms of function
increase so classically the decrease is
so so slow but constantly we can make a
constant
decrease here but on the other hand
there is another level overhead in terms
of quantum stimulation we
which we got to play like a logan factor
here but classically
if you just if after making the the
classical perturbation
just like just do it so this is a
constant overhead here
so this is the this constitutes the main
difference between quantum classical
so class of it is going to be logged
into the six this
log n i mean the either the classical or
the discrete
value of the number of simulations or or
like the
quantum data the the time continuous
time of the simulation
so basically they are going to all be
the login factor but what really makes
difference is these
the other two factors here
okay so this is the the point about how
we are actually going to
actually we have achieved the quantum
speed up the cubic one
speed up in terms of escaping from
center point and the later part is that
we want to
fulfill the the claim that we actually
we can do everything by only constant
evaluation article
so it is clear that for the part of
quantum simulation we actually only use
the
evaluation oracle but how about gradient
computation
so this is actually not really uh this
is not really novel
but actually this is a existing result
due to uh stephen jordan
there's steven jordan previously showed
that for a quantization
for smooth function you can actually uh
uh using only quantum evaluation oracle
to compute classical gradients
so maybe let me just very quickly uh go
through the idea the idea is just like
uh you if you have this kind of
oracle you can make it to make like a
you can use a standard trick called the
fist kickback
to make it to be some kind of phase
queries to the
to the function here and and you know
that if you have a smooth function you
are you can actually approximate the
function
into like the first order tether
approximation like this
and if you apply this kind of function
your position
uniform summarization around a small
mesh at the point
that you want to compute the gradient
you're actually going to have such kind
of form
and after having such kind of form you
can just apply like a inverse quantum
fourier transform
to extract all the information of the
partial derivative simultaneously
and i think roughly speaking this is
like a continuous version of the person
was running algorithm
but i think i think for today's time i
probably won't have
a quick to cover this in great detail
but i think this is actually um
well covered in pre in the in stephen
jordan's paper as well as the previous
two quantum commentimization papers are
due to an apparatus and also
bar here okay so maybe let's just
quickly uh skip this so basically we
just make everything robust
i mean like the for for the for the
perfect case just we don't have this c
here but it's just like
after making some calculations we can
replace all the gradient descent
and an accelerated gradient these are
those kind of calculations
by only using the jordan's error with
the quantity evaluation order
and actually we can make sure that all
the calculations can go through here
and actually this is like the theorem we
first proved uh for the for the escaping
from center points in the previous part
but we want to be careful that
here we actually not only use the query
on student to the uf where we make
the queries to to make the quantum
simulation but also the gradients but i
think after making this calculation
basically using jordan's algorithm to
replace all the
gradient computation by quantum relation
oracle we are actually
proud to say that we can actually delete
this and we just reduce everything to
just
the privacy evaluation article
and i think on the other hand basically
our calculations through that we
essentially show the robustness of
escaping from center points by
grading decent because we know that
gradient descent
due to jordan's algorithm actually has
some noise but actually we can make sure
that this does not
like disturb the performance of
proto-radiant decent too much
so this kind of robust neutral i think
it is it's just intrinsic to such kind
of framework of operating decent
and i guess which may be of independent
interest maybe to even the classical
community here to let them know that
such kind of algorithm really interests
robustness
okay so i think at last maybe let me
also very briefly discuss
about some numerical experiments so
actually we perform some numerical
experiments for our work so for instance
we
consider quantum stimulation on
non-contracted potential wells
so in this case we consider like a
quartet function
you know fourth power function here so
basically we show
we numerically examine that for such
kind of
quartet function with two local minima
doing quantum simulation really like
squeezes along this
direction of the two local minima and
actually it is really going to to these
two points
and actually uh for them i think we uh
also
yeah we also uh consider situations for
for a cubic function
so for this qb function it is
specifically designed to have a
structure where
you are going to have like a you're
going to have a heel in the middle and
actually you just like you're going to
have two ridges around this two
direction
so what we really encounter is that some
i think this is like the
the nicest experiment that we we made
during the
during our project is that we really
observe the phenomenon of like
wave interference so you can see that we
make these two ridges and we make the
quantum solution here
the wave interference really has here i
mean this
you see like these um these parts i mean
this is really
something intrinsic to to waves to
quantum this is just totally different
compared to
the the classical optimization methods
and actually um this
this is more like these two experiments
more like proof of principle
results for a non-contract potential
fields for quantity for
cubic functions and actually we also
make a very careful analysis about
about the dimension claim i mean whether
our quantum algorithm is really faster
than the class variables in terms of
dimension dependence
and we are happy to say that actually
this is the situation i mean
classically we choose the uh for this
specific setting of the parameters and
also i think this is the
part of the partic function that we have
shown so we choose the classical
iteration number to be something like
like 50 times times log n squared plus
50 and quantum like 30 times log n
so we can show that even in this
situation the quantum
the quantum simulation algorithm is
better than the classical error within
in all of the cases i mean uh for the
for this
large part actually it decreases faster
than the classifier
you see like classical algorithm is
actually more easy to be trapped
compared to the class compared to the
quantum here
yes so i guess for the time i should
probably wrap up and let the
audiences ask some questions so main
result is that we give a quantum
algorithm for absolute approx
approximate local minimum with only like
log n squared or epsilon to 1.75
aquarius
so the outcome is like a cubic this is
the cubic mile in terms of n
and also we match the classical best
known result in terms of epsilon
so from the technical perspective we
achieve the speed up by using quantum
stimulation to escape from center points
and also we reduce classical gradients
to on evaluations better than
algorithms so there are also some open
questions so for instance can we give
points very classical algorithm
for escaping from center points so i
guess our algorithm really enjoys the
phenomena phenomenon of being a hybrid
quantum classical
that we only replace one step the
perturbation step but maybe there are
some other a more clearer way of making
the classical cultivation
to to to give a faster classical
algorithm i guess this is
definitely something we it is worth to
think about later
and also maybe another natural question
is that component algorithm
should speed up in terms of our absolute
so we really cannot improve the
average loan dependence in this work
because for the gradient design part is
totally classical
so if you want to make something clever
around this i guess this is going to be
something intrinsic but
i'm not really autistic about this
because i also saw in this workshop that
robin kasari talked about a very nice
work about
like no cons in terms of gradient visa i
think
i think robin's top really answers the
question here i guess
and also beyond local minima does
quantum product advantage for
approaching global minima i guess this
is also some something that in general
for classical optimization on people
after we escape from center point they
really want to um be more ambitious and
think about how to approach the global
medium or at least some
local minima if it's even nice structure
and this is also some
some question that may be a little wrong
to think about
okay so this is the end of my talk and
feel free to ask any questions
thank you
[Applause]
so now there's already one question
inside the q a
sure let me take a look so in the
classical algorithm which is what is the
intuition for the step where they make a
uniform perturbation presumably they
could have done a random walk similar to
how you are with their schrodinger
equation
oh this is a very good question um
i think from my understanding to the
work of china at all i guess
in their analysis if you do like a
random work i mean
something other than the uniform
perturbation i guess it is plausible and
it's
actually uh doable in analysis but it
won't like
really uh bring some advantage here
maybe it's just their analysis too it's
not once enough but
i think actually in our numerical
analysis i mean in this part we just
like
generally genuinely use the uh their
prototype gradient decent method
so in our numerical evidence we feel
that the classical
reading decent is not as bad as logged
into the six so in particular i think
it is like the p here i think the
behavior is more like p to the
uh a three p to the four p l two
somewhere between that it is definitely
about quadratic
but i think it's not as pessimistic
about p to the sixth
i think classically maybe this log into
the six is not tight i mean it's
probably their analysis
it's not one's enough but just in the
original paper the analysis i mean
you can definitely ask whether maybe
some random work or something other than
the uniform preservation whether they
can work
but i think maybe there are some skill
something to improve in analysis part
yeah so um so one uh thanks for a really
very clear very nice talk and really
nice results
uh i actually wanted to maybe follow up
in a more general way on this
on this issue because um uh you know
it's a
it's a beautiful technique for um for
for a speed up but
do you have thoughts on you know beyond
improving the
the classical analysis on on
understanding this difference where the
where the speed up comes from and um how
how much the classical uh whether there
are other
other classical algorithms that could be
just
uh as you said content inspired here
is probably it's just like the the
quantum simulation here is so different
compared to the
classical arabic so sorry can you hear
me
yes yeah i'm sorry it says my internet
is a little bit unstable but
let's read that thank you yeah i think
it's just like the
the constitution is just so different
compared to the class of algorithm i
mean
i mean the cubic speed up here is from
my perspective it's not like a very
like satisfactory claim here i mean this
is probably just the classical analysis
it's not good enough or
or maybe there's and i think maybe there
are situations but there are spaces
around that i think i think from a
higher perspective my method is
our method is definitely very want to
use the simulation to
to uh to overcome the the difficulty in
terms of the
like the the saddle points i think a
furthermore question that we are
actually thinking about is that whether
we can make a
like even largest like a separation
maybe maybe not sticking from center
point but really
to climb through i mean like this
like what is showing this picture i mean
maybe in the case
where we are ready as some locomima but
we really want to get rid of some
some bad local minima and this is really
like we really have to come through that
note that for a set of price we are not
climbing through that we just don't
we just don't like this as we we don't
move but for
for some general cases maybe if you want
to climb on something there's like an
even
more significant one to speed up this is
probably going to make the classroom get
even more
different but this is still some ongoing
work that we probably need to figure out
next
so so on on that on that front have you
looked at
um i mean there's been a lot of thought
about tunneling in the context of
adiabatic
complementation and there are some
negative results there so
do you have do you have uh sort of
preliminary thoughts about
why how one would get beyond those
negative results
um well i guess there are there are
always situations that we can figure out
i think
like my comment to this is probably
maybe like uh because this is like still
like a quantum characteristic result
so my comment is probably going to be
the difference between like a total
function and partial functions i guess
for the quantum part complexity of total
functions
the quantum and classical separation can
be only most polynomial
and actually probably can be at most to
the fourth power after using the font
sensitivities
theorem result and actually recently
figure out by order at all
but i think for partial functions there
can be huge quantum possible separations
i mean
i'm not in general pursuing some uh some
very uh
like uh some very general results and i
definitely know there are some negative
results on the adiabatic set
but maybe i think i'm hoping for maybe
for some specific kinds of
non-organizational functions
we want to see whether it is possible to
reach some exponential or at least super
polynomials
for such kind of non-complex functions
we have time for one more question yeah
i'll ask you a question so
first of all thank you for this very
informative and interesting talk i
really enjoyed it
so my question is i would suspect a
certain pure density of the function f
might be needed so um the the reason i
think of this is
at one point you mentioned this sort of
normal uh
regularity result provided by progen
and as if i remember that correctly in
that result
it will require the function b the
potential b of
x and t uh to be pure all the b x and
the
cause of periodic in t so i might
i would think to get this log arithmetic
in t
maybe some certain say geraldine city
e x of the function f might be needed
and another
point that might be related is that i'm
not sure
whether in the algorithm you you ever
use the uh
qf t2 to calculate the derivative of the
function f
if that is the case then periodicity may
not
may also be needed to get this uh
fourier transform to be accurate for the
derivative calculation
so that's uh um
sure like comment yeah yeah yeah i think
yeah i see your question and i think
both your questions are interesting but
i think
the two things you mentioned there are
related i mean i mean the
the further for the jungle dance result
i mean for this periodicity
the point is this so at the beginning we
are actually at a very unconcentrated
part that we have this kind of
cautionary packet and we want to
simulate that
so the periodicity here is just like at
the beginning we're actually
very concentrated in the middle so if
you simulate for a short enough time
actually you want like the the vast
majority of such kind of
control function will like jump like out
of the range a lot
so actually in our analysis we just like
draw like a specif like a slightly
larger region and make sure if the
simulation time is
short enough actually you won't you
won't make
out of this and if this is just like a
standard trick on partial differential
equation
just like if you don't move a lot and
because this is just like a
like a like estimate for the total
variation distance and also there is
like a
term here to to really bounce back for
the for the tail whether you're actually
going to get out of that
but actually this is in general we can
handle this after having having the was
like the vast majority of the trunk in
the specific region you just need to see
the other parts to be
periodic i mean this does not have any
crosstalk in terms of the in terms of
the
the the quantum field transform you'll
be later mentioned
and that part is is really near for the
to justify that the corrective
coordination
is correct i mean that does not even
have crosstalk with the quantum
that you even with the greater and
decent i mean the quantum field transfer
means this trick of furnace algorithm
because i apply to
greater and decent but the quantity of
cost approximation part is eye to fund
simulation
so this does not have any crosstalk so
hopefully there's this household
yeah i think i see yeah it makes a lot
of sense especially the
yeah it's a localized gaussian
right right obviously so yeah so we
don't need to worry about
yeah exactly
[Applause]
all right